[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
Professor Haldane
becomes the newest addition to
this extraordinary department's
hall of fame.
[APPLAUSE]
[INSPIRING MUSIC]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: We
are fortunate that you have
chosen to become Americans.
It is a pleasure and an
honor to be with you today,
as you make the
promises of citizenship,
and I look froward
to working with you
to support our Constitution
in the days and years ahead.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
[PIANO MUSIC]
JILL DOLAN: Our service
curriculum teaches our students
how to be in the world
with an ethic that makes
a great deal of difference.
And I am very proud of that.
ANNOUNCER: The Princeton
Tigers are headed back
to the NCAA tournament for
the first time since 2011.
[CHEERING]
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: Bill
had a deep and lasting impact
on many, both within and beyond
our university community.
And I am glad we
have this opportunity
to remember, celebrate and
give thanks for Bill's life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNE HOLTON: Sometimes
it's OK to try something
so hard that success is
not a foregone conclusion.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
BAZ LUHRMANN: Get out there
and make the world new again.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
Congratulations
to the great Class of 2017.
Onward!
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[GENTLE STRING MUSIC]